[Music]
now that disney owns the star wars
franchise they're going to make spin-off
films featuring individual star wars
characters wow take certain characters
and just make movies about them in fact
there's already a trailer for the first
star wars spin-off featuring one of the
characters and uh we have it check it
out
you're living in a dream world son now
wake up before you hurt yourself and the
people who love you i train champions
not dreamers do you seriously think that
you could travel for this team
no
do
or do not
there is no try
he was a small-town jedi with big-time
dreams
a notre dame application don't you know
this school is for athletes and smart
guys not blue collar guys like us yoda
here thinks he's gonna play football for
notre dame
hey he's choking me hey chuckles pretty
good
you're two foot tall five pounds of
nothing and you're 900 years old you
belong in a space swamp not a football
field
[Music]
that hard kid
plus there's a thing you can do where
you choke people with your mind now suit
up
and don't let me down
come on tackle out there
yo
get in there kid
i'm ready for this my whole life have i
been
[Music]
i know you can do it
[Applause]
sometimes big dreams
come in small packages
yody
[Applause]